the combined era between tonight's two
starters
is the lowest in sunday night baseball
history
brandon woodruff with an era of right
around two will go
for milwaukee what a year he's having at
seven and four
gavin sheets
nothing for five in the series
one two delivery struck him out swinging
nasty slider down low and inside and
sheets went after it
strikeout number 138
for woodruff
here is jose abreu one ball two strikes
the pitch hey struck him out swagging
back-to-back strikeouts
[Applause]
for woodruff
lance lynn
what a season he's having at nine and
three in a 1.94
era on this season long has hit in all
six games since coming back from his
latest il stint
lynn back in it
after a 3-0 start the payoff
called strike three
paint job lower outside corner here
comes christian yelich
[Applause]
and yelich is a strikeout victim
back-to-back strikeouts for lance lynn
here's willia damas the shortstop
terrific
mid-season acquisition from tampa bay
he's been
their catalyst offensively since he got
here
swinging a miss on a high one
lin strikes out the side
zavala making his seventh start
hitting 167. he's looking for his first
rbi this would be a nice spot and a base
hit to center
around third comes goodwin the throw to
the plate is off the mark and late and
the white sox have the lead
lynn is listed as a switch hitter he is
a right-handed batter but he told me the
other day
after tommy john's surgery with st louis
he had trouble swinging the bat
right-handed so he started switch
hitting owen two the count to lance lynn
a run in with two guns second and third
and lynn has a little
right field that's gonna score another
the throw to the plate's too late on
savannah and the socks have struck for
three
in the second
lance lives first hit in almost four
years drives in a pair
two outs nobody on base for you on
moncada
caught his swings and misses at a
breaking ball
and the inning is over for the white
side we discussed the struggles of
kristin yelich
earlier in the series
he struck out in the first tonight
that's four consecutive strikeouts going
back to last night
two on two out the one two to yelich
called strike three
got him on a cutter to end the inning
brewers get their first two hits but
they strand both runners
the bad news for andrew vaughan he hit
into a double play in the second the
good news is he cannot hit in the two
this time
one and two on vaughn
goodwin to follow and then layuri
garcia
trio do up against woodruff in the
fourth one two
strike three called fastball at the
knees on the inside corner that low
strike was there last night and
in the first
three and a half innings it is there
again for dan is sonia
williams wired wearing a microphone and
talking to his bat tonight
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's a bouncer to the first baseman
abreu he's got a hustle he's going to
slide in and beat adamus beat first
slide by jose
somewhat reminiscent of the play he made
in the rodon no hitter it is going to be
lance lynn who is working on a two-hit
shutout
coming on the bat here in the fifth
inning his big base hit first on the
year back in the second
drove in a pair to make it a
three-nothing game
here comes woody swinging a mess struck
him out down and away with a breaking
ball that time
one down top of the order now in tim
anderson
shade toward right right center in the
pitch
swing of the mouse struck him out
[Applause]
fastball at 96 again that one about
letter high and
tim anderson
no chance on that one
and jackie bradley jr now
is the batter with only one out there he
is boys
get him in here three and two on jackie
bradley jr
and the pitch
swinging on a drive in the right center
it is going to get off the wall
in the second base with a standing run
scoring double
is jbj
and they're on the board that's three to
one
they've just gotten a pitcher up in the
bullpen but woodruff will take the
at-bat
the 3-2 from lynn
called strike three
at the knees on a fastball
and here's wong with two down
fans are up for both teams
swing and a miss strike three lynn pops
his fist
here comes monkatta
single and a strikeout for him today
one two delivery a check swing strike
three
says dan iasonia who really pulled back
on mankato
and uh
not all that happy with the call but it
didn't look all that bad it's another
strikeout
for woodruff
andrew vaughan is the batter yeah
woodruff and narvaez tried to go down
there once again to strike out fawn the
same way they got molcato
and they'll get him this time eight
strikeouts for brandon woodruff tonight
bring up peterson with two on and two
out
[Applause]
and on the first pitch a slow roller to
the right side that will get lynn out of
any troubles two away for sebby zavala
02 pitch on the way from woodruff
struck him out swinging
nine strikeouts in seven pretty good
innings for brandon woodruff
we are at the stretch here at american
family field
white sox leading the brewers three to
one yelich with two outs one and two on
yelich the pitch
ground ball right to anderson he's going
to have to throw to first
and he gets him
michael kopeck works around a little bit
of a command issue
they leave two
we head to the eighth still 3-1 that'll
bring up chase peterson
the pitch swing and a miss hendricks
puffed up
as he heads to the dugout
he struck out narvaez got telez on a
foul out and then fans peterson
that takes us to the ninth
it's still 3-1 white sox
chew away with vaughn still at second
and here is the f-4 mentioned lairy
garcia
as garcia sends a fly ball out toward
left yellow is on the run still on the
move in foul territory nothing won the
count to colton wong
taylor takes off long hits it in the air
this should do it
hamilton and center calling
he's got it and the white sox win
here in milwaukee they avoid the sweep